hace casi tres años que no ha vuelto a
este lugar yo antes vivía aquí esta era
mi casa
la quemaron reagan y su familia
abandonaron su casa en noviembre de 2016
en ese entonces el departamento de pool
se vio afectado por violentos
enfrentamientos entre una milicia
llamada los ninjas que se oponían a la
reelección del presidente denis sassu
nguesso y las fuerzas gubernamentales al
igual que un tercio de los habitantes de
pool reagan y su mujer y sus cuatro
hijos huyen de los combates y se
refugian en la vecina república
democrática del congo había muchos
camiones de militares que pasaban por
aquí empezaban a disparar en el pueblo
allá para papá sólo teníamos un morral
con ropa para los niños y dos pantalones
míos
nos fuimos a pie hasta allá
riegue el regreso a un año después
justo antes de la firma del acto el
fuego
ahora alquila esta modesta casa y vive
de pequeños trabajos
nos da miedo a comprar cosas para la
casa porque cada vez hay más problemas
en el congo congo
siempre hay problemas ya estamos
cansados al igual que riegue la mayor
parte de los 138.000 desplazados
regresaron a publi retomar en la medida
de lo posible una vida normal el
departamento también retoma poco a poco
su papel de granero del congo la
producción agrícola se desplomó durante
la guerra asumiendo la población en una
grave crisis alimentaria estos estanques
piscícolas se rehabilitaron con el apoyo
del gobierno y de la onu y ahora
abastecen a los mercados de la región
en este momento es posible decir que la
población y los productores del
departamento de pulmón
consumen los productos que resultan de
sus esfuerzos detrás de esta tímida
retoma de las actividades pool sigue
marcado por casi dos décadas de
conflicto durante la guerra civil de
1997 el opositor bernard cole la ya
combatía contra las fuerzas
gubernamentales con los ninjas milicias
que él creó después de su exilio algunos
combatientes formaron filas detrás de
frédéric vincent alias un atún y un
pastor que luchaba en ese entonces por
la liberación de pool el conflicto
siguió hasta 2003 y luego reinicio en
2016 el papel del pastor tumi fue
controversial algunos lo acusan de haber
sido manipulado por el gobierno en 2018
finalmente los combatientes entregaron
las armas y esperan desde entonces ser
reinsertados este taller de soldadura es
uno de los pocos en darles una formación
hasta ahora no hemos recibido
financiamiento actuamos con nuestros
propios esfuerzos tengo 28 jóvenes que
formamos aquí y ellos dependen de mí yo
soy el que se encarga de alimentarlos de
cuidarlos cuando están enfermos los
llevo al hospital
todo eso me corresponde a mí emily y los
pueblos de alrededor decenas de ex
milicianos desempleados recorren las
calles
muchos se sienten abandonados por las
autoridades
entregamos las armas para que pensaran
en nosotros pero no le importamos al
presidente es azul
tal vez cree que no somos congoleños la
guerra no nos ha dado nada sufrimos nos
siguieron hasta en la selva con
helicópteros mataron a nuestros hermanos
lo perdimos todo y hoy todavía seguimos
sufriendo
a la amargura de los ex milicianos se
añade el traumatismo de una parte de la
población durante dos años la guerra en
pur se desarrolló a puerta cerrada sin
periodistas y sin ayuda humanitaria la
cantidad exacta de víctimas civiles
sigue sin conocerse y son pocos quienes
aceptan dar un testimonio por temor a
las represalias esta mujer a quien
escondemos el rostro para proteger la
cuenta que su marido fue capturado por
hombres con pasamontañas y uniformados
mi marido estaba vendiendo vino de palma
incluso tenía una botella en la mano
cuando tres hombres se bajaron del
vehículo y lo agarraron lo lanzaron a su
camioneta y empezaron a darle patadas y
puñaladas les pregunte qué había hecho
de mayo me contestaron que eran y ya
entonces les dije que no que él ni
siquiera sabía manipular un arma ni
siquiera un arma de casa desde 2017
hasta hoy nunca regresó
tortura violaciones asesinatos
desapariciones forzosas tesoros y la es
una de las pocas personas en haber
documentado las resultas exacciones
cometidas por ambas partes en pool entre
2016 y 2017 para nosotros indudablemente
se trata de crímenes contra la humanidad
y de crímenes de guerra en pool
y la lucha que llevamos a cabo hoy en
día es para que se establezca una
comisión independiente mientras no se
hable de justicia mientras no se hable
de reparaciones seguiremos siempre en un
ciclo de violencia
en 2018 el gobierno congoleño se
comprometió ante la onu a establecer una
comisión de investigación independiente
una promesa que aún no se ha cumplido
entretanto la república del congo afirma
que el desarrollo y la paz en el
departamento de pool son su prioridad
todos necesitamos paz el congo ha
sufrido demasiado y ahora necesitamos
definitivamente pasar página' hay que
pensar en el futuro y el futuro exige
que el país se desarrolle y para
desarrollarlo justamente es necesario
que el país esté en paz
aunque hoy en día la paz parezca haberse
instalado pool las heridas del pasado no
han sido olvidadas